as I moved north it caused severe
coastal flooding in Georgia and South
Carolina at least two people died in
Georgia when storm surge and rain
flooded communities
Erma sent four feet of ocean water into
downtown Charleston South Carolina the
ocean level reached nearly 10 feet above
normal
David beg no has made his way to
Charleston where the storm surge was one
of the highest recorded in nearly a
century David good morning Nora good
morning you had people here in
Charleston along the battery who were
prepared for what could have been
hurricane force winds
what they got was that storm surge
associated with the tide that set a
record when it comes to tide the third
highest tide on record the water came
from the Ashley River here and just
poured across the battery look at the
video from Waterfront Park it was
incredible as salt water inundated that
area of downtown in another part of
Charleston benches look like they were
sitting in the middle of lakes people
were in boats cars could not get through
the water as people tried they found
that they got stuck south of here in
Savannah nearly 500,000 people had to
evacuate ahead of the storm there and
elsewhere along the Georgia coastline
back here in South Carolina the governor
had 55 shelters on call on standby but
they only ended up needing to use about
25 charlie we talked about the
third-highest record being set consider
this the third highest tide and the
fourth highest tide in Charleston's
history were both set in the last two
years thank you David